also ich als Kaufmann in Zeltweg bin
froh dass es diesen Standort gibt wir
haben viele Nächtigungen und dadurch
eine Jobsicherheit wir freuen uns also
zu uns kommen zum Einkaufen für uns
dieser Standort hier natürlich sehr
interessant mit der Airpower wo wir
unsere Lieferanten einbinden können und
die Wertschöpfung in der Region steigern
können die Gäste haben Freude also alles
perfekt
ich bin Oberst Franz 6 Kommandant des
österreichischen
überwachungsgeschwaagens der
Fliegerhorst Zeltweg ist der größte
Arbeitgeber in dieser Region wir
unterstützen Großveranstaltungen zum
Gelingen solcher Veranstaltungen
brauchte es eine gute Kooperation mit
den Behörden und den Herrn Bürgermeister
und dem darf ich den Staffelstab
weiterreichen der herzlich willkommen
hier in der wunderschönen Sportstadt
Zeltweg mein Name ist Günther Reichhold
ich bin der Bürgermeister dieser
wunderschönen Stadt es gibt eine gute
Kooperation mit dem Bundesheer da ziehen
wir auch einiges an Wertschöpfung und
wir haben natürlich viele schöne andere
Bereiche wie den leingaval oder auch der
steirerschlössl Kundschafter vorbei und
dann kennt sich überzeugendes ist
mein Name ist Michael Ransmayr bin
Vorsitzender der erlebnisregierung
Murtal danke unseren wertschöpfungspaten
und Botschafter für viele Region des
österreichischen Bundesheer herzlichst
dem Urteil
ich im ursprünglich aus dem aussehende
Lehrer hier am Flieger als Zeltweg
absolvieren dürfen in deswegen auch
extra heruntergezogen ich bin die Saskia
ich bin luftfahrzeugtechnikerin
mein Name ist Patrick Wöss ich bin
Oberleitner und einsatzpilot am
Eurofighter die hier im Herzen
Österreichs gelegene Heimat des
Eurofighters ermöglicht es uns innerhalb
vom einstelligen Minuten Bereich an
sämtlichen Außengrenzen der Republik zu
sein wir sind für Euch da
[Musik]